Save the Joker. Sign here.
You even earn that in a year?
In the final hour.
There's. Sweet and sour, shall we?
Going up.
Is a city state. Wait wait, wait.
I'm good for. I can get you the money.
Show off. You got me jealous.
The story about the Joker and the thief.
Memorial Hospital somewhat proudly presents
Doctor Rainsford Sneed. And the much
celebrated doctor Jack Dawkins. Now we have a
fine one for you today, gents.
Leg shattered, falling down a mine shaft, was
it? The question, though, is who cut.
Heads? Cup, Cup.
Cup. Cup.
Me.
I bet you can't do under 43.
A pound, says 29. When have you ever had a
pound? As soon as you lose. Gentlemen, Doctor
Sneed here seems to think that I can't
amputate this leg in less than his record of
43 seconds.
I beg to differ. So this will be the worst
30s of your life.
But I promise I will make it as quick as I
can. Your favorite memory? Take your mind
there now.
Mm mm mm mm mm.
Timing.